hey guys my name is Jeff today it is the
21st of April and here's a buncha news a
number of independent sources have
suggested that the xbox one was sold 18
million enos Neville Upton head of
eSports group gfinity mentioned the
figure in a recent press release where
he said we are delighted to announce the
launch of our tournament builder app on
xbox one which will enhance the gfinity
offering and enable us to reach xbox
one's 18 million users globally he later
clarified that Microsoft did not confirm
these figures to gfinity but rather he
ascertained the number from a variety of
independent sources published earlier
this year including gamespot sister
sites at d nuts if the number is
accurate the PlayStation 4 is surging
ahead quite a bit given sony revealed
they'd sold 36 million ps4 consoles back
in january independent analysts have
estimated that ps4 sales will exceed 100
million units in its lifetime Microsoft
no longer shares console sales figures
publicly so the designer Jeff Kaplan has
spoken out about Titan the company's
cancelled MMO that was supposed to be a
spiritual successor to World of Warcraft
the project was announced in december of
2010 before being officially canceled in
September 2014 Kaplan explained you had
a really amazing group that was working
on Titan they were really talented
individuals but we failed horrific alee
in every way in every way that a project
can fail it was devastating he went on
to say that the team felt they were
under pressure to succeed jutsu Titans
failure and that is what eventually
spurred them on to create team-based
multiplayer shooter overwatch finally
Mirror's Edge catalyst has been delayed
ahead of its closed beta which launches
tomorrow developer dice announced to
that the game has been pushed back two
weeks and will now arrive on jun 7 in
north america and june nine in europe a
post on the official website from design
director Eric odel doll explains that
the games social play features which
consists of things like creating time
files and leaderboards are being powered
by a brand new online technology which
will be tested in the closed beta and
are a key part of the game the delay
will allow dice to make adjustments
before launch based on the feedback let
me know down in that comment section if
you're keen to play Mirror's Edge
catalyst be sure to head to gamespot
well we've got stories on lawbreaker and
elder scrolls legends that's everything
you have for you today but be sure to
pop by same time tomorrow for the
biggest stories of the entire week I
will catch you then